départ roger gicquel copenhague
ouverture du conseil européen les
élections européennes aurait lieu en
juin 1979 recyclage des vieux papiers
une seule usine en france pour une
consommation annuelle de 6 millions de
tonnes
la termine bientôt commercialiser c'est
le fer de lance des exportations de la
régie renault avant la sortie de son
film un papillon sur l'épaule et
interviews exclusives de lino ventura
qui ne parle pourtant pas beaucoup et
qui met des mamans le printemps qui
n'encourt être étouffée par le héros
grisaille qui lui barrer la route à je
crois fait une bonne brèche le ciel
était bleu et aujourd'hui même s'il
faisait frais parfois sur une bonne
partie de la france est une bonne chose
pour ceux qui partent en congés ctaq et
j'en suis pas redonné les devants et le
week-end qui vient à une bonne allure
dans les prévisions
demain le temps sera assez ensoleillé
les gelées matinales sont pas si le mas
un parisien va le nom et la lorraine
des vents forts sur la manche et la
méditerranée
mais ce n'est pas désagréable
malheureusement il y aura des exceptions
et ne forme pas sur le parc avait un
ciel très nuageux des pyrénées aux alpes
et au jura et même sur l'arrière-pays
l'intérieur sur cette moyenne et risque
de perdre avait raison il peut même y
avoir de la pluie à montagne et la neige
au dessus de 1500 m dimanche encore des
pluies sur les alpes et l'inox et vous
tend la joue et brumeux rage dans le
nord du pays ailleurs frais et
ensoleillé dans ce mini en tout cas de
l'année
on est sûr d'en trouver partout où il y
à des stations de sports d'hiver rouler
d'hier je vous le confirme aujourd'hui
l'arrière ça va ce sera une pleine
saison donc en station les images prises
dans les pyrénées que vous voyez le
confirme comme elle confirme que le
printemps a du retard mais en cette
saison
la montagne est loin d'être le seul pôle
d'attraction pour ceux qui cherchent la
détente la belle france vous ouvre les
bras erreur comme elle seule sait qui tu
fais ce qui te fait bon vivre tout
simplement malheureusement il ya aussi
la belle france soulier est inquiète
il fait beau en bretagne c'est le
meilleur moment
mais la marée noire est toujours là nous
ne dirons jamais assez notre admiration
pour ceux qui nettoient les plages c'est
une rude corvée qui est loin d'être
terminée mais il ya aussi une autre
bataille rude
elle accueille dans le monde doivent
passer en versant de l'argent dans les
discours et les autres choses qui
sauvait même si c'est important
cette bataille psychologique en quelque
sorte c'est celle qui consiste à ne pas
faire de la partie polluée bretagne un
désert en ce sont 18 pendant les 20 p
pour ce qui me concerne je voudrais
surtout que les images horribles que
nous vous avons montré néo définir les
personnes d'aller en bretagne cet été
parce qu'à ce moment là tout sera propre
sans doute ou pas plus pollués
qu'ailleurs seulement pour l'instant il
faut bien l'avouer c'est le pcs qu'en
bretagne jean paul fleury a téléphoné à
quelques-uns de ceux qui voient la
saison pas très bonne
matt 2 minutes 40 secondes
comment j'adore alors écoutez nous
n'avons pas les communications
téléphoniques de jean paul fleury je
pense que nous allons vous les montrer
dans un as tous nous les faits voulait
faire entendre dans un instant montrer
c'est la lutte des noirs qui a attiré de
très nombreux inventeurs venus tester
leur technique pour dissoudre le pétrole
1 que le coupé nous disperser est venu
aussi proposé leur brevet en tout cas il
ya quelque chose qui marche si on l'a
essayé à portsall c'est le papier
journal il absorbe si kylie pétrole pour
un kilo et demi
notre confrère le parisien libéré a
montré l'exemple en patronne en cette
expérience il en montrant en première
ligne en quelque sorte avec quelques
tonnes de papier difficile pour nos le
résultat est excellent sauf lorsque la
couche de pétrole est trop épaisse mais
sur les plages peu paul v on nettoie
beaucoup mieux le sable avec le papier
qu avec des pelles avec et puis sept ans
et demi que les spécialistes du plan
polmar s'y intéressent pas rival mais
c'est une expérience qui est comme
toutes les autres
la suite a donné dépend de ce qu'on
décidera d'en faire là où on a le
pouvoir de décider de s'en servir
alors j'appelle maintenant la régie pour
savoir si un arbre les communications de
montagne voilà voilà les de la
température en bretagne si j'ose dire
sur quant au stick pour l'été
nous n'avons pas beaucoup d'importance
et alors c'est aussi très important
c'est que nous n'avons pas vraiment
comment est la situation sur les places
de la région de hausse des revenus bien
meilleure qu'elle a été on nettoie ton
tant qu'on peut et si personne n'a pas
été tellement touché d'ailleurs
comparativement à faire est ce que tout
ça pour la saison prochaine évidemment
le mal est fait malheureusement oui vous
avez déception pour les femmes et les
absolus moyens et pour l'été vous avez
déjà des discussions mais le courrier
qu'on échange est restée sans réponse
depuis déjà une quinzaine de jours
comment se présentent les plages région
de digne à gradignan il ya eu aucun
aucune solution
oui et pour les vacances de pâques
madame comment marcher les affaires pour
vous arrivé en me demandant si la cote
était plus jeune c'était dans ton et les
mots
nous voterons encore dans quoi
l'an prochain 179 au printemps pour les
cantonales et tout de suite après en
juin pour les élections européennes
seule charge en rien pour la situation
issue des élections que nous venons de
connaître
mais ça promet tout de même une période
politique animé c'est vous pensez que
l'européen de copenhague qui vient de
décider que les élections européennes
aurait lieu en juin 79
monsieur giscard d'estaing est arrivé à
copenhague en fin de matinée il a été
accueilli par le prince henrik l'époux
de la reine et par le premier ministre
d'alors savais qu'il y avait ce qu'on
peut appeler un contentieux entre
monsieur giscard d'estaing et monsieur
joergensen ce dernier pendant la
campagne électorale en france en février
avait déclaré devant le national press
club de washington que monsieur
mitterrand un bon partenaire pour la
communauté
on s'en était ému en france on avait
considéré que ce n'était pas du jeu est
bien ce matin dans la voiture officielle
ouverte à copenhague
on a mis les points sur les i avant de
clore l'incident
définitivement monsieur joergensen a
regretté d'abord les commentaires faits
autour de sa libération
monsieur giscard d'estaing lui a rappelé
les bonnes règles de la vie
communautaire qui voulait que confiance
et discrétion soit de bonnes choses
en période en parle le père connaître
leur peau ensuite les travaux ont
démarré sur la création d'une fondation
culturelle européenne
puis sur une déclaration à propos de la
démocratie en europe qui doit être plus
rentable
cela bouge et une fois de plus vérifier
qu'un ordre du français et européen est
souple et modifiable à mars
en effet après le déjeuner offert par la
reine margrethe à et le prince henrik de
danemark au palais amalienborg les neuf
chefs d'état et de gouvernement devaient
décider
commencé leurs entretiens par deux
sujets que les observateurs attendaient
plus tard après la photo de famille
premier thème donc les élections
européen au suffrage universel direct
il fallait enfin en déterminer la date
et bien ce sera donc entre le 7 et le 10
juin 1959
donc non je dis juin 79 pour la france
dans 14 mois jour pour jour et c'est
valéry giscard d'estaing en personne est
venu le réveiller il est confirmé aux
journalistes dans les couloirs de la
conférence
avec à la clé ceci une déclaration de
l'europe des neuf sur les principes de
la démocratie
on a adopté cet après-midi un texte des
amis et inspiré ravi communautaire un
texte large sur les droits de l'homme ne
s'agit pas d'une formule et les italiens
le savent bien eux qui vivent en ce
moment
le cauchemar de l'enlèvement d'aldo moro
à ce propos il y aura une déclaration de
solidarité à propos de monsieur deuxième
sujet le projet de fondation européenne
pour la culture et pour valéry giscard
d'estaing
ce n'est pas une question mineure
puisque la france souhaite obtenu
apparemment le siège de cette relation
soit à paris avec une dotation
financière au départ suffisant à lui
assurer une vie autonome et active ainsi
pourra exercer la liaison culturel et on
l'espère humaine de cette europe voilà
pour les décisions de cet après midi et
les problèmes économiques a remis un
ordre monétaire viable
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement ont
décidé d'aborder cette question dans la
deuxième partie de leur entretien
après la suspension de séance et
peut-être aussi ce soir au dîner avec
dans l'air et du père des 213 me cas des
thèmes de réflexion de la part de la
france car est venu le moment a dit le
président de la république peut parvenir
un système stable de relation des
changes dans la communauté pour cela at
il dit il faudra imagination et l'état
au total il s'agit d'un pis aller de
concertation de progrès des idées mais
aussi d'un conseil de retrouvailles
entre les neuf une fois malgré les
hypothèques et les neuf
le gant disponible est en tout cas
décidés à demain pour la suite de ce
bilan qui est d'ores et déjà ce soir et
concret est il qu'à panade
aujourd'hui c'était le calme politique
en france mais voici une déclaration qui
ne manque pas d'intérêt elle et elle
émane du bureau politique du parti
communiste et elles viennent ni infini
le bureau politique du parti communiste
français accuse les dirigeants
socialistes et vous allez voir que les
termes sont assez forts accuse des
dirigeants socialistes en conduisant est
lui dedans une de 12 mars une la
violente campagne contre le parti
communiste
ils ont les socialistes cherché à
justifier l'abandon du programme commun
et l'adoption d'une stratégie qui n'est
pas celle de l'union de la gauche
soulignant la gravité de cette
orientation laisse en auto ministre
demandant son manteau d'y faire obstacle
alors je pense que vous savez qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes y pas de contestation
c'est que star haufor discussions au
sein du parti communiste cette
déclaration semble faire un contre feu à
toutes les critiques qui sont émises en
ce moment au sein du ministère de la
responsabilité des échecs de la gauche
que certains mettent aux comptes
totalement
cet avis est que certains partagent
jimmy carter décidé d'ajourner la
production de la bombe à neutrons contre
l'avis de bon nombre de ses conseillers
et concours est rappelé son opposition
par exemple gerald ford ou enrique dix
ans la décision était attendue elle a
été annoncée et cela presque au même
moment où leonid brejnev assiste à des
manoeuvres navales et avertissait dans
un discours les états unis la mise en
oeuvre de la bombe en 2002 et il se
serait le coup d'arrêt aux pourparlers
sur la limitation des armements en fait
entre les américaines signifie qu il n'y
ait pas eu de marchandage mais tout de
même convaincre oncologiques dont nous
n'avons qu'une faible idée finalement
jimmy carter a pris sa décision tout
seul et les soviétiques considère que
ces gestes de bonne foi
cette bombe à neutrons je vous le
rappelle c'est le projet le plus
terrible qu'on puisse imaginer c'est une
bombe atomique
on ne détruit pas l'environnement mais
qui détruit les hommes et les seulement
les hommes les bâtiments résistent les
abris aussi mais pas les gens qui sont à
l'intérieur éventuellement on n'a pas
encore imaginer la parade à ces
terrifiants les américains voyaient
comme une arme défensive et pour
compenser la supériorité du conditionnel
des soviétiques c'était de la stratégie
la haute stratégie mais moscou considère
cette arme simplement comme l'art
nucléaire de la troisième génération
une arme qui peut être on parle tant
d'autres au désarmement moment où on
doit en débattre à l'onu monsieur
giscard d'estaing lui même proposera son
plan le plan français la décision
d'ajourner la mise en route on est un
pauvre cette arme était à l'ordre du
jour du conseil de l'otan le 18 avril
prochain
certains européens y était favorable
aujourd'hui jimmy carter est ce la
raison pour des raisons humanitaires
mais cette décision politique n'est-elle
pas déjà dépassé par la technologie
en tout cas de grimpeur
c'est un jour comprenait que ses
conseillers carter avait bel et bien
décidé la semaine dernière d'annuler le
programme de la bombe à neutrons des
allemands qui faisaient le dessinateur
d'américains qui compte espèces et des
eaux menacent de mode mon sac dans
américain est partiellement revenue sur
sa décision
mais l'annoncé la longueur c'est dans la
négociation pour les armements 30 et
l'amérique son terme une carte qu'elle
pourra s en donner en fait la défense de
l'europe avec sa part dans ce froid
c'est la façon cela était partiellement
éclipsé par la volonté de parvenir un
accord avec nos vies nos contrats
conclus pour airbus avec les américains
ça n'a pas été sans mal mais ça y est la
compagnie eastern airlines et le
consortium européen airbus industrie
contrat qui porte sur l'achat par la
compagnie américaine de 24 merlus à 300
+ 9 options avec d'autre part 25 options
sur le futur aig
airbus est bien les bilans sont lebedev
dans les airbus à courcy avec seulement
200 places pour l'airbus a300 cela porte
à 135 les comics les autres passaient
dans le monde entier certainement pas
fini si une compagnie américaine a
estimé que cet avion était rentable il
ya gros à parier pour que d'autres
compagnies américaines pour pays se
lança dans une version exploitation la
négociation qui vient de s'achever a été
je voulais dit extrêmement dit
s'il est certains font déjà la fine
bouche en disant que les européens du
cds nus du cd a pas mal d gilles
d'exigence américaine mais certains
autres experts pensent que ce n'est pas
le cas vous l'avez évidemment remarqué
le jour 90 et pas seulement en tout cas
depuis le début de la semaine un des
récents c'est l'augmentation minutes
appuyer une augmentation constante
d'ailleurs le papier on s'habitue très
vite à un être inondées on reçoit en
jette
les boîtes aux lettres et les corbeilles
on prenne du ventre résultat nous avons
en france et quatre garçons le papier et
celle des ce deuxième déficit après le
pétrole
n'oublions pas que nous importons pour
40% de nombreuses familles les écoles et
les émirs en ce domaine sont les
canadiens et les scandinaves
la première chose qui vient à l'esprit
c'est bien sûr désire récupérer les clés
et ça commence le journal officiel le
journal officiel utilise du papier
recyclé aussi un bloc plus l'avancé gay
le papier en couleur et bien il est
fabriqué sous l'égide de marjolaine
60,18 par l' agence nationale pour la
récupération l'élimination des déchets
et c'est une erreur cycle est possible
un journal un journal quotidien alsace
imprimer depuis deux mois sur papier
recyclé et enfin voici un magazine sur
papier agréable mavs quoi il s'appelle
numéro spécial il publie son numéro un
aujourd'hui tout rares et il présente
ensuite dans crevant donc le papier
recyclé c'est possible
les belges fabriquent leur feuille
d'impôt probablement envie papiers
français rosicky tandis que d'autres
déclarations de revenus est presque sur
papier de luxe ce qui est parfaitement
inutile de nous montrer l'inversé claj
de nos économies et même dans notre
style de vie mais il va nous montrer
aussi les problèmes que ça pose
des participants tristement qui se
fanent est pourri sur les murs les
arbres les monuments parfois des
centaines de milliers de journaux de
tracts que l'on ne finit plus de jeter
au total 20 tonnes de papier rien fera
avec 20000 tonnes de papier pour coup
cela part été nommé n'ai pas grand chose
à peine 0 5% de la consommation annuelle
qui désormais approche les 6 millions de
tonnes une formidable montagne de
paperasse dont un tiers seulement les
réutiliser plus souvent ou en cadeaux
d'emballage le reste les journaux est
abîmée de toutes sortes
le reste part en fumée dans les
décharges publiques autant dire que la
situation économique et ne permet plein
telle question
fini le temps du mépris à l'égard du
vieux papiers américains japonais
allemands qui ont consommé depuis notre
île déserte
le second déjà plus de 25% de leurs
imprimés en france on n'en est pas là 4
% seulement des pâtés et recycler la
récupération n'est pas encore entré dans
les moeurs et les cas de gaspillage sont
nombreux les annuaires par exemple pour
imprimer les 15 millions d'exemplaires
distribués chaque année il faut environ
30 tonnes d'attaquer leur récupération
représenterait une économie estimée à 15
millions de centimes
il suffirait qu'un simple système des
changes soit organisé des journées de
l'annuaire en quelque sorte
malheureusement aux ptt en adoptant la
couverture plastifiée on avait eu l'idée
de cette matière était un point pour
recycler les récupérateurs ne veulent
plus entendre parler de ses annuaires
on a donc plus les moyens de dégager ce
vieux papiers le simple augmentation de
son taux de récupération représenterait
une économie d'environ un milliard de
francs avec un taux record au carat sur
100 l'indien donne l'exemple dans ce
sens
là par exemple vous avez une école des
environs de colmar café un ramassage de
papiers composé d'outils pour cent voire
même peut-être plus de tracts électoraux
et bombes pour cette école ça
représentera un certain potentiel
d'argent qui peut varier entre 300 400
500 euros dans ses vieux papiers sur
ensuite revendu puis recyclés dans cette
usine située à te calmes dans leurs
usines en france équipés pour le
désencrage une technique qui permet la
réutilisation des vieux imprimés pour un
usage graphique les pouvoirs publics qui
encouragent cette formule ont d'ailleurs
donné l'exemple en faisant simplement le
journal officiel
tous les papiers recyclés dans
l'administration pratiquement personne
ne s'en est rendu compte depuis le début
de l'année le journal l'alsace
une première balle française et lui
offre un look et avec du papier recyclé
et les préjugés à l'égard de ce paquet
sont tenaces une question de teintes
difficile car ce voile à vrai dire non
signes comme pour les livres de bataille
de la blancheur et si vous ne faites pas
la différence
regardez bien demander à votre libraire
ce papier portant le sigle particulier
avec la pause entier rick perry est
rejoint pour la première fois un
constructeur français a vendu plus d'un
million de voitures à l'étranger en un
an
vinet serrure est revenu en fait c'est
sa vocation et sa nécessité d'exporter
via tous deux signé anna torv et plus
quatrième constructeur américain
american motors un accord pour vendre
des voitures aux etats-unis mais aussi
pour monter des voitures et notamment la
bientôt fameux combat f18 peu entendu
parler mais que la régie lance
aujourd'hui sur le marché s'inscrit tout
à fait dans sa politique c'est une
voiture classique
la future faire violence pour renault à
l'étranger elle sera construite
également dans plusieurs pays européens
l'air 18 ne va pas remplacer tout de
suite la r16 selon l'anil mais ce sera
pour l année la r18 se situe un tout
autre niveau que les autres modèles que
je viens de citer jean louis burgat en a
fait
et il a beaucoup apprécié ce dernier de
la régie renault et c'est jean-louis
burgat la 18 ans fait ses quatre
voitures un cocktail de deux moteurs et
de deux finitions dont les prix
dépendent de vivre de file à 36,500 la
tl moteur 14 centimètres cubes sept
chevaux la gtl même moteur mais finition
luxe la ts moteur 16 150 centimètres
cubes neuf chevaux
la gts enfin avec le moteur 16 150 la
munition luxe mais aussi une boîte 5
vitesses en plus sur la ts et la gts
renault propose une boîte automatique en
option mal
sur route pas de surprise le
comportement d'une traction avant bien
intégré légèrement vireuse c'est normal
avec bloqué ce maxi volontairement
limité entre 150 et 160 suivant les
modèles enfin des reprises moyenne sur
l'a7 chevaux bonne sur l'a9 je veux
qu'ils correspondent à des rapports de
pont assez long en vue de réduire la
consommation et c'est efficace puisque
avec la 7 chevaux sur un circuit route
autoroute ville ne ménageant pas
l'accélérateur je n'ai jamais dépassé 9
litres 50 au sens pour la 9 chevaux avec
boîte 5 vitesses
la consommation peut être inférieur ou
encore de près d'1 ligne côté négatif
une direction un peu lourde à basse
vitesse et un nouveau sonore améliorée
freinage disque à l'avant tambour à
l'arrière je n'ai jamais pu le prendre
en défaut et il complète fort bien ce
bilan routier près cette affreuse
finition bonne période bordeaux plaît
mais abandon définitif du compte-tours
et absence gênante de tablettes sous le
pare brise la position au volant ce de
conférer sièges avant et arrière sont
remarquables pour des stablement à la
régie ont misé gros sur la 18 qui
s'attaque à ce marché des voitures
moyennes avec coffre séparé de
l'habitacle qui constituent 52 % des
ventes en heure avec ses 4 m 38 de long
15 cm de plus que la croissance 5 son
pont arrière rigide
cette traction avant et de conception
très classique mais cela doit garantir
sa solidité et la facilité du métal
rouge est pour un modèle à vocation
internationale
renault avait voulu construire un
produit homogène
en définitive je crois que le pari a été
tenu
la 18è sur le marché leur place dans
cette gamme de vertu au moyenne du
gaulois semblablement le meilleur
compromis entre
le confort les performances le probable
à la consommation pas mal ce même
regarder la caméra de noces et fabien
jean claude narcy les autres nouvelles
de ce journal dans le sud-liban l'ol
paie a fait savoir que les soldats y
sera au moins fourni au sud liban
seraient libérés et les corps des
soldats tués restituer à condition que
les deux survivants du commando
classement 11 mars
la viande et légumes et autres membres
soient restitués aux autorités civiles
de cisjordanie d'autre part le chef
d'état major israélien a présenté aux
responsables des forces de l'onu son
plan pour le retrait initial des forces
israéliennes du 11 avril les rumeurs
faisant état de la mort de trois casques
bleus enfin c'est au cours d'un incident
qui a opposé à les fedayin près de tirs
ont été formellement démentie
aujourd'hui par l'elysée à beyrouth de
nouveaux casques bleus français sont
arrivés avec du matériel 80 soldats y
convient d'aider kajima débarquer les
incidents je voulais dit se succèdent
donc et la tâche des casques bleus en
général et pas facilitée par l'hostilité
que leur témoignent certains bénévoles
et des lettres vivantes a lancé
christian mas et le suisse andré qq
merlin gh adressé à leurs familles ont
été remises aujourd'hui à un bureau de
l'agencé france presse de lagos
maman d'un troisième a dit chan on ne
connaît pas encore la teneur de celle
nouvelle vague attentes en italie pour
la seconde fois depuis l'enlèvement
d'aldo moro des brigades rouges se sont
manifestés a remis à jean le résident de
l'association industrielle a été
légèrement blessé par balle yvon chotard
président de la commission sociale du
cnpf souhaite que l'expérience au
premier emploi pour les jeunes océan 77
sera conduite à 68 enfin il a annoncé
que d'ici à quelques semaines
le cnpn sur les propositions concernant
une revalorisation de qualification de
la main d'oeuvre féminine
vous allez voir maintenant les images
qui sont celles de l'épave de
l'hélicoptère écureuil qui s'est écrasé
il ya un accident a fait un mort et deux
blessés parmi les morts le directeur
miral de messerschmidt monsieur l'homme
felder et le général toulouse délégué de
la snia ce pour l'europe occidentale le
sur yonne ont clamé même s'il s'agissait
d'un vol d'informations sur cet appareil
conçu pour le marché civil
le premier président de la cour des
comptes monsieur bernard bec a pris ses
fonctions aujourd'hui en présence du
premier ministre et membre du
gouvernement
le premier président a souligné
l'importance accrue les fonctions de la
cour des comptes et s'est inquiétée
notamment de l'alourdissement des
charges l'a fait que ces mots mme subra
vague concernant monsieur désiré arnaud
qui était atteint par la limite d'âge
un village de l'époque néolithique a été
mise à jour près de villeneuve tolosane
à côté de toulouse une dizaine de
cabinets s'ornent de pierres travaillées
s'étend sur une superficie de deux
hectares
on a découvert des malades ringim de
pêche les mesures des céramiques
selon les spécialistes ce village
remonte à plus de 3000 ans avant
jésus-christ il aurait abrité les
agriculteurs sédentaires de la région
midi pyrénées les fous ils vont durer un
an et par logement sont dus ville le
salon du prêt-à-porter se tient à partir
de demain la porte de versailles voici
en avant première la silhouette de la
femme hiver 78-79 proposé par plusieurs
oeuvres yves saint laurent et pour le
confort avec une veste en les mêlant
concert sur une blouse flanelle la jupe
portefeuille
quant aux lourds côtelé avec des
collants de l'aide aux christian dior
une silhouette de fluide avec une robe
pour un ménage
les manches sont larges et français le
tout animé par un gros noeud de taffetas
écossais pour les frileuses les
superpositions de guy laroche sur un
pantalon de flanelle un chemisier un
gilet de lainage de style irlandais a
dit elle a voulu un avec non rationnel
confortable avec cette jupe culotte en
jersey de l'année courrèges a pensé un
manteau ponchos en lainage apens très
long avec des manches - ben et puis hein
en chemise serge lepage pour ce qui
apparaît lit un deux pièces en crêpe
rose à fuir avec ses harmonies paco
rabanne a dessiné une veste droite une
jupe en l'ensemble étant l'énarque et
agrémenté de la cram
enfin chez chanel un ensemble pantalon à
pinces en flanelle noir et une veste
droite en lainage sur une blouse ans bon
ce réel de toutes les deux toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal en fin de soirée toute fin de
soirée
23h10 aujourd'hui water qui est jean
pierre pernaut merci